ce que m'a dit l'archevêque de saillon
monseigneur celui ne me l'a pas dit à
moi mais ce qu'il dit de même atteint
dans l'humanité sans paraît extrêmement
important parce qu'il lit par exemple il
n'ya nous avons une totale liberté
religieuse de notre église n'est pas
victime de persécutions alors il fait et
taboo pourrez le lire d'ailleurs d'une
certaine incompréhension dans les
provinces qui lie à certains nombres
quelquefois de petits chefs enfin qui
prennent des libertés avec les la
politique générale mais il il m'a il
assure enfin qu'il n'y a pas de
persécution religieuse ça me paraît
important j'ai discuté avec son côté
peter pan de l'ong masayo
les i je dors je m'excuse ce n'est pas
monsieur x man qui m'empêchera de parler
ici ce soir d'ailleurs à présenter
présenter je représente un grand parti
qui s'est battus pendant des millénaires
les et vous taisez vous je sers monsieur
je sais quand vous appelez je serai que
vous voulez un leader se taire je
voudrais continuer ce qu'il dit demander
combien de temps je vais vous laisser
parler tout à l'heure mais je commence
il faut être un provocateur et vous ne
représentez ici vous un moyen rien faire
nous avez
menti pendant 50 ans
si vous êtes complice un jour mais ce
que je voudrais le monde est ce que je
m'en veux dire à part ce que je voyais
alors là je veux dire aussi quelques
mois non non répétait la crête des
excuses
excusez vous avez un policier enfin
soyons raisonnables est ce que je vous
ai répondu s'agit dans ce sens il s'agit
de vannes une manière correcte je vous
demande des excuses ou je ne reste pas
monsieur glucksmann je prie monsieur
andrieu de s'excuser d'avoir dans son
journal menti pendant cinq jeunes ont
servi je lui demande sujet du coup là
je vais demander à ses assurés
il faut que nous ayons une conversation
qui compte qu'il soit à la hauteur ne
m'écoutez qui soit à la hauteur du
problème qui est posé il ya des enfants
et des femmes sont demandez lui de
s'excuser où je m'en vais il ne s'agit
pas de singer seul et
non ce que c'est moi qui ai parlé qui
tirait
donnait le droit mas jury et je vous en
prie mais vous me traitez de flip boom
et l'été vous qui m'avez nous étions des
boues qui va même
vous êtes je m'excuse si lui
demandez lui de s'excuser et je roule je
retire en fait ce que je dis c'est que
sincèrement on pourrait parler des
choses ce ne serait pas moi pour kim
enfin parce que vous êtes je viens vous
devez avoir une très bonne opinion de
mme ou non lorsque je dis je c'est
demander que de s'excuser le bras
n'étaient pas très raisonnables
il s'excuse où je m'en vais écoutez moi
je vous propose d'écouter je veux que
vous vous excusez est-ce que vous irez
vous excuser de les formuler des excuses
réciproque non je veux qu'ils se
présentent des excuses réciproque et
qu'on parle maintenant des gens qui se
noient au vietnam non moi je vous
demande de vous excuser de ce que vous
avez tout à l'écouté vous n'avez pas vu
de morts alors s'excuser vous n'avez pas
tous les deux
laboratoires du débat
doit arrêter de se la voir lit que je
fais un policier tout à l'heure aux
mails a dit vous n'avez pas eu je ne
vais n'avait rien dire ce moment là je
vous demande de vous
parce que vous disiez je crois que j'ai
regardé garder les regarder ce que
j'apprends que nous partions ensemble à
leurs annonceurs
dommage petite séance de jaurès on
entendra enfin les réfugiés
naturellement connotation
a brillé vous restez je ne reste pas en
partir aux individus ah ben voilà c'est
la démocratie tout le monde en a libéré
la démocratie monsieur monsieur andrieu
vient de déclarer que je tiens un flic
vous
rendre ici
alors que je vais dire je dénonce
l'opération cabinet en pleine de nantes
l2 parce que je peux plus aller c'est
méchant drieu parler depuis à moi elle
aurait refusé lé film a vite fait pas du
tout
sur le vietnam est aujourd'hui vous avez
vous avez invité son personnage parce
que vous savez bien que comme lorsqu'on
va leur donner
moi je dis ce personnage
comme alors je dis rien avec manor est
une punition est une provocation c'est
ce qu'il a fait c'est bien moi je ne
reste pas avec lui voilà vous étiez vous
quand le débat n'est pas méritée
landrieu non ce débat méritait pas ça
rend cette race bien moi je suis
d'accord nous partons ensemble ce que
j'aurais demandé à monsieur andré yeux
c'est ainsi qu'est vous parce qu'on vous
voit pas là mais non mais revenez aussi
andrieu la faisant même discuté et il a
posé une question laissée il a posé une
question vous voulez partir d'angers
d'être aux jeux libres si si je vais
partir immédiatement
est ce que vous voulez écoutez je suis
traité de crétin de figues dattes ont
laissé loin devant nous et ça fait
beaucoup cendrieux je vais pas m'excuser
trépident crespin c'est dommage
d'abandonner un peu l'habitude de partir
au cours des débats alors sa mère
j'aime le débat démocratique est
totalement faux c'est totalement faux
c'est au cours de cette campagne est
scandaleusement fossé il ya d'abord
l'intervention permanente du
gouvernement du premier ministre et même
du chef de l'état et naturellement les
représentants des autres listes ne sont
pas du tout les mêmes privilèges et puis
il ya les petites listes seules qu'on
appelle petit je ne sais pas pourquoi
puisqu'elles sont tout de même 80 noms
qui elles disparaissent complètement et
ne sont absolument convié rien ou
pratiquement à rien eh bien ce ne sont
pas les règles du jeu normal de la
démocratie
en ce qui concerne particulièrement les
petites listes je ne sais pas pourquoi
il n'ya pas aucune organisation pour
l'instant je pense que ce sera réparé en
tout cas niveau pee nos
églises temps de parole elle passe dans
les journaux télévisés ça commençait
hier c'est aujourd'hui la technique elle
notamment
les petites listes elles ont 80
candidats comme les autres les voilà
quelqu'un qui veulent conduire une
petite liste vous voyez ce qu'on en fait
c'est ça la démocratie ici dans les
studios de télévision
vraiment
je crois qu'ils sont extraits telle ou
telle espèce résidence du mas la façon
dont le gouvernement et le président de
la république conçoivent leur rôle par
rapport à la formation
répond à paroles je voudrais dire que
monsieur jean edern hallier était dans
la salle il était invité ils
représentaient ici deux journaux ils
devaient présente il devait publier
demain matin le compte rendu de cette
émission bon il était convenu entre
monsieur et dernier qui avait eu un
temps de parole hier dans le journal de
13 heures bien qu'ils n'interviendraient
pas ce soir dans la soirée monsieur
eternal y est je le constate n'a pas
tenu la parole n'a pas tenu les
engagements qu'il avait pris aussi bien
devant la rédaction en chef de tf1 que
devant le service politique de tf1 mais
l'engagement principal c'est de
respecter la règle démocratique c'est ça
qui est important quand on ne la
respecte pas on provoque des incidents
de ce genre la violence
physique fait non à la violence non nous
sommes témoins nous sommes les
téléspectateurs sont nous juge tout ce
que nous faisons nous le faisons devant
les téléspectateurs les téléspectateurs
savent que monsieur et dernier est passé
dans le journal de 13h et que tous les
jeudis un mauvais on met du débat tient
mais il n'était bien les évacuer par la
force des gorilles c'est une être
écoutés je suis assis au milieu d'eux où
il n'était pas elle n'était pas invitée
dans cette émission
vous croyez que nous arriverons à parler
de monsieur marcher marcher marcher ce
match mais aussi je suis toujours à zéro
monsieur marché
alors tout d'abord
il est évident que sur cette question
je suis le plus à l'aise
compte tenu que vous avez tous les trois
étaient ministre voulait encore madame
veil moi je ne n'ai jamais été vous
souhaitez est jeune et il est permettez
françois mitterrand et je n'ai et je
n'ai jamais mois coupé la parole à
personne je n'ai jamais eu je n'ai
jamais eu la possibilité d'interdire la
télévision à qui que ce soit or les
téléspectateurs ça fout la voir arriver
les téléspectateurs savent pour l'avoir
entendu souvent que j'ai été amené à
protester y compris quand vous étiez
premier ministre monsieur chirac a
protesté énergiquement contre le fait
que l'information le débat à la
télévision ne sont pas organisés de
manière démocratique et en particulier
dans les périodes touchant aux campagnes
électorales
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
m'associe d'agorad cette brutalité
inadmissible à l'égard d'une personne
qui sans doute voulait venir dire
qu'elle n'était pas d'accord sont des
méthodes inadmissibles je répète même
jour je protestais me permettez pas 50 g
à faro nous revenons ne me coupait pas
je proteste
je proteste contre cette chose
deuxièmement je regrette que lorsque
j'ai été amené à plusieurs reprises à
demander plus de démocratie dans
l'information en général dans notre pays
je regrette messieurs que et madame que
vous ne nous ayez pas soutenu parce que
on commence toujours par le parti
communiste et après on finit avec les
autres voilà pourquoi la démocratie elle
ne doit pas se diviser et effectivement
toutes les formations politiques sans
exception
doivent bénéficier d'un temps d'antenne
égal lorsqu'il s'agit d'une consultation
électorale aussi importante que la
prochaine voilà simplement ce que je
voulais dire alors je voudrais pas plus
notre entretien sachets plat il est
humain il est 13h27 déjà monsieur oui
oui voyez nous allons jusqu'à 13 heures
34 tenir un mois encore a parlé et
j'ai besoin a parlé avec david
permettez j'aimerais dire que limité
alors si je peux rien dire avant la fin
d'émission monsieur mitterrand parce que
moi j'avais pris plein de notes en
venant dans l'autre version non je
n'aurai pas le temps je le sais déjà que
j'ai pas le temps j'ai juste le temps de
mettre en colère je commence maintenant
non c'est le système de l'information
française qui fait comme ça j'aurai le
temps une minute de m'énerver juste de
m'énerver de paraître pour un petit
merdeux un petit jeune de [ __ ] la
pagaille partout je préfère m'en aller
tout de suite si j'avais su je n'aurais
rien dire j'aurais dormi beaucoup plus
tard donc je souhaitais votre présence
dans l'avoine dans ce studio pour parler
des problèmes de la jeunesse lorsque
nous aurons eu tort
nous aurions eu le temps d'en parler
c'était n'ont pas de chance on a les
seins tout de suite et c'était pas de
chansons dont il était question
de parler pendant 10 minutes au moins de
la sphère georges marchais dont tout le
monde se fout strictement je vous
signale que la jeunesse française se
fout strictement de ce que monsieur
marché faisait pendant la guerre sale
vais complètement égal ces intérêts
seraient plus la jeunesse de savoir ce
qui se passe et comment le parti
communiste en caisse de l'argent pour le
dépenser après notamment la mairie de
bagnolet ses intérêts seraient mieux de
savoir comment gaston defferre diriger
sa mairie socialiste qui n'est pas un
modèle de société à marseille
s'intéresserait plus de savoir les
jeunes français comment monsieur raymond
barre qui est arrivé il ya cinq ans ou
quatre ans où je ne sais plus combien
temps a dit que les salaires ne seraient
pas diminué mais qu'à augmenter les
cotisations de sécurité sociale c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant que tout ce
que vous racontez georges marchais on
s'en fout de georges marchais il faut le
savoir ça de ce qu'il faisait pendant la
guerre ça nous est complètement égal le
problème de drogue de la façon dont on
le traite les ministres français on s'en
fout n'y a jamais un jeune ministre de
la hat de la jeunesse en france il y en
a jamais eu c'est tous des vieux
regardez monsieur soissons enfin vous
allez pas me dire que c'est un homme
représentatif de la jeunesse regarder
comment je suis habillé ils sont plus
souvent biais com - les jeunes que comme
monsieur soissons il faut quand même pas
rêver tout ça ce sont des métiers j'ai
encore pris plein de notes au fur et à
mesure que vous parlez ce que je
voudrais savoir ce qui nous a intéressés
c'est de savoir à qui les travailleurs
immigrés paye les loyers qui paye on a
vu tout à l'heure des gens qui disaient
on paye 700 francs par mois je voudrais
savoir qu'ils encaissent de l'argent
pour louer des poubelles pareil c'est ça
que je voudrais qu'on dise c'est pas de
savoir comment on peut faire pour
changer je voudrais qu'ils osent tout
les mois demandés 700 francs à des
travailleurs immigrés pour vivre dans
des poubelles dans des taudis ça c'est
ça que j'aimerais qu'on m'explique pas
ce que moi je ne le sais pas c'est pas
la force et la formation qui me dit je
voudrais savoir pourquoi monsieur boulin
était suicidé ou s'est suicidé ou on ne
le saura jamais pourquoi monsieur
fontana l'itc signé pourquoi la terre de
brebis n'a jamais été éclairés pourquoi
le juge renaud on sait pas ni pourquoi
ni comment il a été assassiné j'en ai
d'autres la seule chose que je peux vous
dire monsieur mitterrand je m'enfuis de
vous avoir parce que je suis fier d'être
là je peux vous le dire on s'en aperçoit
peut-être pas mais vous pouvez pas
imaginer ce que c'est pour un jeune
d'avoir la possibilité de parler une
minute c'est pour ça que j'avais peur de
ne pas pouvoir parler parce que ça
n'arrive jamais faut bien se mettre en
tête non ça n'arrive jamais regardé
l'émission qui a eu hier soir sur
antenne 2 les dossiers de l'écran enfin
vous n'allez pas me dire que les mots
ont été concernés par la contrée
services et les abandonner c'est
vraiment la chance et bien je sais on
était obligé côté vous exagérez
l'information je suis obligé de l'examen
brochet pour résumer je la résume à ma
manière que j'essaie de lire rapidement
mes notes ce que je vous donnais en tout
cas c'est généralement c'est un
avertissement j'ai peut-être du culot de
faire ça je suis obligé de le faire
comme ça parce que je dois faire vite ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que la
jeunesse désespère elle est profonde et
profondément désespéré parce qu'elle n'a
plus d'appuis elle ne croit plus en la
politique française et moi je pense qu
est la règle générale résume en un peu
bien raison ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que le désespoir et mobilisateur
et que lorsqu'il devient mobilisateur il
est dangereux et que ça entraîne le
terrorisme la bande à baader et des
choses comme ça et ça il faut que les
grandes personnes qui dirigent le monde
soit prévenu que les jeunes vont finir
par virer du mauvais côté parce qu'ils
n'auront plus d'autre solution voilà je
vous remercie de m'avoir laissé parler
ça très bien bon alors on va d'abord on
va parler de l'oeil on reviendra
évidemment sur les photographes
photographie mais évidemment je me
tourne vers le professeur
j'ai pu écouter je suis désolé mais
excusez moi c'est pas très poli
d'interrompre c'est pas très poli que la
télévision n'a pas invité un étudiant
pour parler du problème étudiant je me
transforme alors vous avez vous encore
je suis venu parler du problème
étudiants dans une démocratie un citoyen
étudiant en droit de parler de son
problème oui vous comprenez la côte est
joué allez-y pas les deux buts en deux
minutes par les deux minutes et puis
elle parle et je vais dire ce que j'ai à
dire si vous l'aviez fait dans une
émission avant d'écouter moi je suis pas
responsable envers ses positions et je
suis venu dans un des rares d'intervalle
où un individu peut s'exprimer en direct
je suis vraiment désolé n'interrompt
votre mission oui oui mais qu'est ce que
vous voulez dire alors je vais dire ce
que j'ai à dire sur les histoires
étudiants non mais quelle histoire
étudiante ne savais pas qu'un projet
jospin ah ben oui mais ça il ya des
projets de 2010 cascio nationale à plein
j'en attends qui était qui et des
vitrines tchèque et d'évoquer de la
bagarre qui a un mort de malik oussékine
et là tout d'un coup ça intéresse parce
qu'il ya du sang qui a coulé vous
comprenez est autrement l'éducation à la
télévision on s'en tape oui alors je
viens parler de l'éducation écoutez
c'est pas le sujet en voit parfois ce ne
sera jamais le sujet à la télévision
vous avez dû le pen vous avez du match à
la une en permanence leur élection vous
ne parlez à rien pas de projets que vous
faites simplement d'un d'aligner des
chiffres et des statistiques vous vous
foutez de la gueule du monde notamment
je parle pas de vous mais ce niveau mais
en général des médias
ce qui va se passer c'est que c'est
évident c'est que la direction va donner
l'ordre de couper l'antenne si elle a
coupé si elles coupent l'antenne moi je
me le plante dans le vent et n'en fait
pas ça un coup donné le risque et vous
allez voir mais non mais ne faites pas
ce que vous allez voir jeudi à la
direction monsieur bourges c'est pas
pour rien que j'ai menées non mais bon
ce sera contre moi et c'est vous qui
n'ont verserez médias on me censure on
nous met la vie est trop précieuse la
vue précieuse que si on la laisse
s'exprimer en liberté mais librement
vous désole de cette de cette inclusion
mais des fois la réalité rejoint la
fiction non mais je vais dire bon
écoutez je vous donne trois minutes et
puis vous expliquer 3000 us il prendrait
le ton parvenons venant là vous n'êtes
pas honnête alors là c'est pas bien ça
c'est pas bien l'honnêteté la télévision
j'en vois pas beaucoup ces temps ci vous
comprenez vous avez perdu 18 points de
crédibilité en quatre ans au niveau des
journalistes à la télévision c'est dans
le monde diplomatique
cet avantage sofres je ne parlais pas
beaucoup de ça à la télé
visibilité des journalistes et de
monsieur poivre d'arvor les fouilleurs
de merde oui on n'attende pas beaucoup
elle est et il est gentil mais
n'attaquez pas mes confrères suspectons
ça me gênerait bissau je n'y est pour
rien c'est moi qu'on exprime librement
un citoyen droit de s'exprimer librement
à la télévision française c'est comme ça
fera vous y faire parce que sinon ça
explosera vous comprenez je voulais
télépathe de sécurité il faut laisser le
diallo c'est elle et moi je suis native
constructif et j'ai des propositions
constructives réel des propositions qui
évite la bagarre bah oui mais là si vous
êtes plutôt lewis est un exemple de va
vous ne laissez pas le choix vous avez
vous les êtes un exemple de bagarres
plutôt la couette au je suis désolé nous
vous rendez compte de comment voulez
vous faire passer vos idées à télévision
en ayant avec vous un couteau c'est pas
possible il peut rien il n'y a pas de
moyens de s'exprimer dans ce pays
démocratique mais si quand même il ya
deux mois par tous à partir des comités
ad un des syndicats pas de moyens je
sais c'est quand même il ya une langue
de bois oui bon on parle le livre
n'existe pas vous n'allez s'est jamais
exprimant écoutez je pense pas que ça
puisse durer longtemps ce laissez-moi
m'exprimer si vous me censurer il y aura
de la bagarre dans les cinq il y aura de
la bagarre dans la rue jeudi prochain
une manifestation
si jamais je ne peux pas m'exprimer
aujourd'hui il y aura de la bagarre dans
la rue vous comprenez vous n'avez pas
donné la parole aux étudiants il faut
que les sites mais moi eh bien c'est pas
mon rôle moi donner la parole aux
étudiants un rôle des médias oui mais
c'est le rôle des médias des médiateurs
sans arrêt on donne à la parole donné la
parole à la caf vous donner la parole à
la destruction vous êtes uniquement
branché sur la merde on veut construire
on peut construire une université
correction est en train de se battre
quand un ministre acceptera de venir
discuter de proposer quelque chose de
compréhensible
il propose du flou que les étudiants ne
comprennent pas comment voulez vous
qu'ils acceptent ça ils vivent dans des
conditions déplorables
le monsieur le ministre ne s'intéresse
absolument pas à ces conditions il
propose d'un coup débarras il y gère ça
comme un cheptel de bétail vous
comprenez moi je n'ai pas de haine
contre monsieur jospin mais pourquoi
pourquoi il nous donne un texte
incompréhensible flou au possible
pourquoi il s'intéresse pas aux
conditions de vie ce sont des êtres
humains qui étudie et quand on étudiera
dans des conditions humaines de savoir
sera beau vous comprenez le savoir aux
quelque chose de beau on doit être beau
très bien m'écouter voilà vous a entendu
ces gentils maintenant nous laisser
travailler merci je veux non annoncés
yen ont coûté lalanne ont coûté alors la
france aux lyonnais alors vous n'êtes
pas sympathique avec avec moi moi je
faisais rien fait d'autre pas
sympathique avec les téléspectateurs qui
attendent cette émission vous venez de
parler vous avez faire un coup d'éclat
pendant cinq minutes
maintenant soyez gentil ça c'est le
voulait à moi je veux une explication
n'est donnée par mois je suis pas je
sais pas mais j'ai jamais une
explication correct et cohérente à la
théorie pour expliquer j'avais eu aucun
problème mais il peut pas y en avoir une
maman de l'état capable d'aligner une
explication parce que vous prenez les
gens pour des cons parce qu'ils sont pas
cap de pas capable de suivre un
raisonnement plus de trois minutes vous
dites ces gens là ce sont des débiles
sur leurs coûts plus de trois minutes
vous angèle moi je crois j'ai confiance
dans les gens écoutent et merci soyez
gentils maintenant on va et de repartir
un cadeau
merci
voilà désolé vous
écoutez si vous avez été exprimées quant
même savez vous avez des propositions
mais sûr mais sûrement relations
constructives mais fait les aux
personnes de adéquat qui sont capables
voilà bon merci
bon allez
c'est elle c'est ce qu'on appelle le
mauvais oeil sur une émission aux
professionnels craint alors je pense
qu'il est toujours à l'antenne oui
j'espère alors professeur oui qu'est-ce
qui vous excusez moi je suis désolé mais
c'est vraiment indépendant de ma volonté
utile de vous le dire je suis désolé de
ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
bonsoir vous avez sans doute vécu un
début de soirée mouvementée et une
soirée inachevée nous vous devons des
explications je vous dois en tant que
responsable de l'information sur cette
chaîne d'antenne 2 des explications il
s'est passé en effet un événement grave
ce soir sous vos yeux un événement dans
chacun prendra librement la mesure vous
savez quand n 2 et europe 1 ont cherché
à organiser ce qui se fait rarement
france une audition publique c'est à
dire de faire réunir un certain nombre
de jeunes qui interpellé des
personnalités de différents milieux et
de tous horizons
nous avions
choisi une trentaine de jeunes parce
qu'ils étaient capables de poser les
vrais problèmes que la jeunesse connaît
actuellement trente jeunes venus de tous
les coins de france de tous les milieux
de toutes les conditions sociales il y
avait des jeunesses communistes parmi
ces 30
le principe était de laisser ces jeunes
expliquer leurs craintes leurs espoirs
puisque cette 7e ce sont eux qui sont
touchées par le problème du chômage en
priorité l'émission était prévue et
organisée avec le plus de sérieux et de
rigueur par les meilleurs journalistes
des deux équipes antenne 2 et europe 1
l'émission était prévu pour se passer de
la façon la plus vivante la plus ouverte
la plus vrai
cette personnalité encore une fois de
milieux différents avaient accepté ce
risque cet échange qui devait se faire
devant vous sans problème et voilà ce
qui s'est passé j'ai résumé reprises
vous faites chez vous si vous êtes
favorable à l'emploi des jeunes et si
vous avez par exemple ou tout chômeur
qui viennent le spontanément vous voir
vous demander de l'emploi si vous êtes
plutôt par exemple si vous leur demande
une qualification comme on voit partout
dans les annonces d'acord peut même avec
des tas donné de d'expérience voire 5
ans minimum d'où les problèmes de
premier emploi est également le problème
des femmes attendez je vais répondre
monsieur dalle mais vraiment je suis
d'un dragon
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas qui je dois répondre
je ne sais pas qu'il doit répondre je
suis con pour aller au scandale faut
savoir que là vous êtes en train de vous
présenter à titre personnel etc mais
vous êtes quand même quelqu'un qui est
responsable de chômage je sais moi que
dans votre entreprise vous fait 333
millions de francs de bénéfice soit 33
milliards d'anciens francs ce qui fait
quand même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
je sais ges le palais des congrès
blement jusqu'à la fin que s'il ya un
minimum de calme certes on peut de temps
en temps mais
vous n'entendrez n'aime pas françois
parent mais d'autant plus le problème il
est de savoir si vous voulez echanger
qu'un dialogue s'établissent si vous
préférez que ça soit comme vous le
souhaitez c'est à dire un petit peu
pagailleux je crois qu'il est important
que chacun puisse s'exprimer françois
vous avez la parole il faut pas la
garder longtemps mais ceci ne saurait
même pas de ce nom vous avez bien deviné
dix ans que ceux ci par là j'en ai pour
même pas 30 secondes juste pour dire que
d'autant plus que dans votre entreprise
vous employez beaucoup d'os des femmes
qu'elles gagnent à aulnay sous bois qui
est le département je suis
seine-saint-denis 3000 francs par mois
je 3000 francs par mois oui oui oui
53% de votre production à l'étranger le
talent hors norme à jeudi la bce en
réponse
la seule question que je pense monsieur
dalle je dis moi c'est dommage que dans
ce plateau d'autant que tout au début on
disait qu'ils n'ont même pas pu venir
alors que charles fiterman demandait de
venir sur ce plateau dit ce rapport
[Applaudissements]
j'arrive à la tête le tapis dans la
salle d'à côté oui je crois que le sud
je vois ça me donne une explication
explications il était convenu à l'avant
ce que c'était une émission dans
laquelle nous indiquions un certain
nombre de personnalités qui n'étaient
pas des représentants des formations
politiques
c'est moi finir laisse moi je suis moi
finir je vous donnerai la parole tout de
suite mais laissez moi finir 6
[Applaudissements]
c'est que la plus grande organisation
syndicale de force je voudrais pouvoir
dire
ouï dire et vous le verrez que la
blesser
[Applaudissements]
écoutez écoutez non mais faut une fois
il faut une certaine non mais attends ce
que pensent vos camarades comprenait pas
ce que je suis désolé je dis moi la
liberté d'expression en l'occurrence
elle est de laisser parler tous ces gens
qui sont là entre nous bon d'accord
[Applaudissements]
s'il est poussé non laissez moi parler
je vais vous dire une chose nous avons
un programme de remplacement nous allons
le passé immédiatement l'émission se
termine
[Applaudissements]
monsieur
jusqu'à plus ample informé ce sont les
journalistes qui font les émotions et
pas la cgt
[Applaudissements]
il était donc tout cela pour un
véritable dialogue malgré les efforts de
domnique laurie de robert namias et de
lubero vous l'avez vu il n'a pas pu
avoir lieu la cgt les jeunesses
communistes et des éléments du parti
communiste ont utilisé ce soir dépossédé
inqualifiable et je veux dire qu'ils ont
fait volontairement il y a eu devant
vous une obstruction une distribution de
fausses cartes
les jeunes qui étaient là ont déployé
des banderoles et transformer cette
soirée en manifestation voilà ce que je
leur ai dit quand vous n'étiez plus but
là
je suis le directeur de l'information
d'antenne de concert
[Musique]
vous venez de mon frère à des millions
de français en direct
[Applaudissements]
la
jeune actrice du goût
[Applaudissements]
mais
rappelez moi
nous nous avons une certaine conception
de la liberté d'expression
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non seulement vous ne voulez pas vous
expliquer ou laissez vos camarades de
votre âge s'exprimer à l'antenne
librement et en direct mais les jeunes
qui sont venus de toute la france pour
s'exprimer devant des millions de
français exprimés leurs angoisses leurs
problèmes vous les avez empêché ce soir
de s'exprimer
[Musique]